hi I'm Erik Bosse and HBO's Westworld
released a second mysterious trailer for
its upcoming second season now as is
typically the case with Westworld the
more you stare at this imagery that
deeper into the maze you wander until
you reach the center of the truth and
you say to yourself oh that doesn't look
like anything to me and seriousness I
did find lots of subtle details hidden
throughout this trailer that could be
hinting at where season 2 is gonna go so
let's review this frame by frame and
spoiler warning in case you want to go
into this season blind but yeah a minute
yet can't help it so join me and watch
this first clip look at this world this
beautiful world
we built us water together
okay this trailer was produced by series
co-creator Jonathan Nolan himself and he
said that since it aired during the big
game he wanted to start off with
stereotypical American Western imagery
that you would see in all those car and
beer commercials and then blow
everyone's mind as they realize it's
actually a promo for murderous robots
the music playing here is a full piano
cover of Kanye West's run away keeping
in with us shows great tradition of that
saloon player piano covering music from
other genres looking at this songs
deeper meaning I love the thematic
connection to the events on the show
Kanye's lyrics are making a toast to the
douchebags embracing his badness and
warning loved ones to run away from his
destructive behavior there's definitely
a parallel between that idea and what
Dolores is saying here the last we saw
her it was during a toast during which
she embraced her true violent
independence by murdering Ford now she's
warning us to run away from her
destructive behavior because yeah she
has no intention to play it nice anymore
in those early shots we could see the
hand of Maeve as it pushes her
daughter's maids decision at the end of
season one was to refuse to escape the
park instead stay in and find her
daughter now more about Maeve's journey
in a bit but let's move on to the next
section dreams come true
a world where you can be free
next we see the recurring image of this
trailer the charging Bulls that the
editing mr. X us into thinking that
these were the Bulls on the ranch but
then it pulls back to reveal these are
artificial steers in the lab below in
front of a broken screen with a
malfunction overhead light as a lab
descends into chaos there's a few things
I just love about using this bull
imagery for one it evokes the Running of
the Bulls tradition in Pamplona Spain a
pastime which like Westworld is a
violent alight with violent ends that
thrill-seekers do to show how tough and
macho they are actually fun fact in the
movies city slickers it's exactly what
those bored venture Craven men are doing
at the beginning of the movie before
they decide to get their rocks off with
a western adventure much like the
visitors of West world but second this
imagery echoes a line from Dolores in
the very first episode when she explains
the cattle on her ranch to Teddy that's
the cutest deer rest to follow verbally
make him good an animal herding the
Judas deer is a steer that leads the
others into the slaughterhouse while its
own life is spared trade art but in that
moment that was some sneaky
foreshadowing of Dolores his role as the
Judas steer within the clockwork of this
narrative a host leading Teddy whom we
later found out was also a host to his
own slaughter while Dolores was spared
to repeat this process I think the
steers in this trailer are meant to
reflect this idea in season two it looks
like Dolores is once again set up to be
the Judas steer who leads other hosts to
get slaughtered but it's interesting how
later we see that it's actually Maeve
who's leading those charging bulls and
sees them one remember she was given the
ability to control other hosts and now
it looks like she's using a stampede to
attack the Telos security does this
suggest that maven Dolores will be
opposing forces seeking revolution in
their own conflicting ways one
commanding hosts who murder innocent
humans trying to escape them and the
other commanding hosts to merely
overthrow the oppressors trying to
confine them
I know chew on that media idea as we
move on to the next section
this world deserves to die
okay lots of interesting shots here
first there's Bernard a company in a
task force overlooking this big body of
water if you look closely there's a
bunch of corpses washing up on the shore
down below it looks to me like Bernard
may have ridden up here after that shot
of him with Elliott Stubbs in the last
teaser this may also be the same scene
from that teaser where we see him
looking down confused at a dead washed
up tiger it sounds like season 2 will
feature Bernard and a small group of
human survivors struggling within the
park as the hosts begin to take over
maybe they're surveying that carnage of
a bunch of corpses that may have been
dumped in a river and washed up
downstream in this lake however are we
seeing Bernard here or Arnold the
co-creator of the park whom Ford
designed Bernard to look like the reason
I bring this up is check out this next
shot of a host getting or strained in
the lab that is Peter Abernathy the host
cast as divorces father but remember a
previous narrative cast him as the
professor the leader of a cannibalistic
cult who was obsessed with Shakespeare
which was of course the source of his
reveries he's violent delights have
violent ends we could be seeing him
malfunctioning under that old narrative
and reset in this new narrative which
would place these events in the past
long before the current timeline that
would actually makes sense because
remember at the end of last season
Charlotte sent Abernathy out of the park
to smuggle out part data but another
reason I think this might be taking
place in the past and we might be
looking at Arnold instead of Bernard is
look at this dude in the background in
the upper right doesn't that kind of
look like the young version of Ford that
we saw in the flashbacks you know when
they ate CGI Denis Anthony Hopkins he
looked all weird of course this could be
someone else and yeah while it would be
surprised if the show tries to trick us
again with dual timelines a season two I
think it's inevitable that we will see
past events in flashback form showing us
more of the origin of the park and the
delos corporation sneaky motives things
that we still know very little about
other than that Delos wants this AI
technology for more than just
entertainment there's another shot of
that division of Union soldiers that
older William and Teddy came into
conflict with last season remember we
last saw young William played by Jimmy
Simpson having massacring all the
Confederate soldiers since Simpson is
announced to return for the second
season maybe we're seeing him here on
horseback as he travels on more of his
journey to become the man in black
decades later there's also this creepy
shot of Bernarda
the half-baked no key host except an
item by the way we know this is Barnard
not Arnold because an Arnold today hosts
weren't made out of this milk goo just
yet they had a more Android frame
underneath the skin exterior and there's
a quick shot of Teddy looking alarmed as
a hand covers his mouth
we were really know what's gonna happen
Teddy the season of them and he just
kind of looks terrified as Dolores drags
him along and she murders everybody
let's move on because this is your
[Music]
we've lived by your promise Martina
we can save this world okay in this
section notice this shot of a fancy
cocktail party with the lights of a city
outside the windows that is Logan back
there brother-in-law - William whom we
last saw him sent off on a horse without
his clothes so I'm guessing this is
another flashback to this time before
coming with William to the park but
notice how none of the guests at this
party appear to be moving so yeah these
are hosts this could be like a work
party put on by Dell O's remember which
Logan and William worked for to show off
their new models of hosts one thing that
would excite Logan to drag William into
the park then there's a shot of older
William ed Harris the man in black and
the pouring rain my name looks to me to
be Lawrence remember last seen having
outlived his usefulness and bleeding out
hanging from a tree we saw him hanging
again swinging from that tree in the
last teaser with a horse pulled up in
the background behind him so I suppose
William has returned and found another
use form and then after shots of
Clementine examining her own hand and
reflection and her own humanity and soul
chaos erupts behind her and more shots
of the bull Stampede wrecking these
security guards we see their Judas steer
Mays she's wearing more battle-ready
attire than when we last saw her leaving
the train and it's interesting that her
face shows up right as lorises voice say
we can save this world which [ __ ] fuels
my theory that Maeve might emerge as a
hero of this story with Dolores as a
villain and let's move on to this final
section
[Music]
we can burn it to the ground
[Music]
from the ashes building
[Music]
our world okay here there's another shot
of a Native American from the ghost
nation tribe according to Hector in
Episode four of last season the ghost
nation possesses insight into West
world's secrets including the maze and
these figures called shades a shade
sacred native lore they make figures of
them the man walks between worlds
you were sent from Hell to oversee our
world
I'm really hoping season two will show
us more of the ghost nation's mythology
we also see the aftermath of the della
Scala massacre notice the wolf that
passes through this is the same wolf
that appeared in divorces visions of the
Wyatt massacre in episodes 2 and 10 of
last season remember an artificial wolf
head also appeared in the background
during a flashback with Laursen Arnold
maybe this wolf is meant to represent
the animalistic violence of the Wyatt
narrative that Arnold's stored inside
the laws and then there's this
interesting shot of Maeve and it looks
like Hector they're looking up at
falling snow now look closely the
background there that would be a person
wearing a kimono I think they are in
samurai world here remember the end of
last season tease the existence of other
parks beyond west world including one
with an SW logo samurai world recently
the show's website was updated with
these hints of the existence of six
total parks with one of them showing
this image which when you look it up in
Reverse Google image search rings that
much hero Tunica in japan's nara
prefecture after some shots of a fight
in the underground map room there's a
blinking mystic shot of these dudes
wearing bandoliers and black masks now
if you remember in episode 8 of last
season Charlotte describes something
like this when she was talking about
boards upcoming Wyatt Meredith credit a
horde of masked men to terrorize guests
and proselytize come advertise the
coming of some end all villain named
Wyatt perhaps these guys are those
terrorists which Dolores will now
command on her Wyatt rampage actually
you can see one of these guys the one
with the long hair flanking Dolores in
the final shot and then all milk emic
muscles throws a dude against this
machinery look closely that machinery is
part of the 3d printing technics used to
construct hosts bodies kind of the
artificial womb that this fella just
slithered out it's just pretty
terrifying to see
shove a like human back into this thing
the creation of the machine mutilating
its creator by returning him to his old
wounds likes this final shot of Dolores
says she says our world according to
Jonathan Nolan is the one shot in this
trailer that won't be in the show it was
not just for this trailer but yeah it's
a very bold declaration of war from the
new conqueror of West world a question
for you guys do you see Maeve and
Delores as the hero and villain of this
story respectively where is it the other
way around in your eyes and about those
two who do you see as the true hero of
West world William Teddy Bernard
Stubbs comment with their thoughts down
below or tweet me directly I do boss and
follow new rock stars on Twitter at new
rockstars for updates on her videos and
of course subscribe to new rockstars for
deep analysis and explainers of this
amazing West world series actually did a
video on the first teaser to come out
last summer and explanations of the
timeline and big mysteries at the end of
the first season in I am super looking
forward to covering in season 2 more
when it premieres on April 22nd and if
you really like us some want to help us
grow you can contribute to this channel
on patreon a big thanks to all of our
donors especially Kenny Smith thanks for
watching bye